this podcast and every other podcast on
my channel is supported by patreon
patreon lets me pay editors artists and
make extra fun content you can get
ad-free versions of podcasts ability to
submit questions for podcasts for
certain tiers on-screen shout-outs and
more it is especially helpful for this
podcast because it is pretty niche it's
never gonna get enough views to even
cover the editing costs so the patreon
supporters are really the reason it
exists thank you to the podcast hello
everyone i'm alana welcome to another
episode of video game writing 101
today's guest is tim shafer tim for
anyone who doesn't know who you are who
are you what do you do
hi my name is tim uh i am a writer of
video games i have been for
30 years i um i started at arts right
out of college and worked on a bunch of
adventure games in the 90s
and started double fan productions in
2000 and i'm still running that studio
today look at you go who'd have thought
not me
how do you feel about monkey island
coming back
that's exciting i mean uh
it's um
i'm really excited for the fans and for
that team to be to be working on it you
know we've been doing a lot of um
sequels and uh
remasters at double fine for like the
last five years and so it's there's been
a lot of that um it is fun to look back
but we're also really excited about you
know doing brand new stuff again that's
always exciting love brand new stuff but
i am going to ask you about the sequel
psychonauts 2. i loved it tim i loved it
um
i had heard that you said at some point
that you wouldn't make
psychonauts 2 unless you felt like you
could top psychonauts 1. what did you
feel like the point was that you were
ready to make psychonauts
all right well
there are a lot of different things that
led into like just a lot of time we've
gone by i like to you know we have to
make something different every time we
make a game so we don't usually do
sequels because we like to do like what
about a heavy metal game instead you
know and um
so there were a bunch of ideas right
when psychonauts one ended i had this
like google doc which is like what about
a mine is going inside the mind of a
gambler and like what about um trying to
put ford's mind back together and had
all these ideas that some of them uh
made it into this game so it was really
i and i had like all of raz's family's
names you know i'm really into the
backstory you can talk about that but i
like how to also figure it out and then
put it kind of shelved it for years and
then
you know we made that um
a broken age game you know a lot of that
thought was like wow with crowdfunding
we can go back to these things people
love that don't exist anymore like
adventure games well they do exist but
they um aren't uh popular
well i feel like they're as popular they
just didn't get as popular as everything
else got
you know like
still you can always sell 200 000 copies
of it
exactly
exactly it seems it seems like yeah that
seems to be the number um
but the thought was like oh and people
aren't being served the games they want
they want adventure games they can serve
themselves by crowdfunding and then
after making that i was like well you
know the games that really feel are
underserved are like bright colorful
character based 3d uh action adventure
platformers you know like they used to
be so much they were like there's a big
lot of them in the early 2000s just like
tons of these games and um that's really
what i like to play like i like like i
like games like that and um i wanted uh
more of them and so i thought well i'll
just just make exactly the kind of game
i would like to play that's the dream
jokes put some jokes in there
uh so i like i said i love psychonauts
too and there's one thing that i really
wanted to ask you about it because it's
the one thing that i was like wow i
definitely couldn't do that all the rest
of it i could totally do totally oh easy
i feel like psychonauts 2 has a very big
cast
and i feel like i very much understood
every single character there are a lot
of things that i've written i feel like
i tend to be very insular where you can
understand the main character and maybe
their immediate circle but psychonauts 2
did such a good job of fleshing out a
lot of characters and i don't even know
how i would approach that i don't know
how to phrase this question but i guess
what i'm asking is like
how did you balance making
everyone feel that that compelling
making this very large group feel like
an actual family like i don't even know
where i would start on making a cost
that big and having them all feel
equally fleshed out
i thought i mean it's awesome that you
felt that uh yeah it stuck with me for
ages i was like damn like that's i love
all of these characters like it really
did when i was like watching the credits
i was like wow i like fell in love with
everybody that's amazing that's awesome
the second game or the first thing
i think both but i feel like the second
game is even bigger but i um
uh i think about that stuff a lot uh
i go back to the first game when i had
to write um the design document for all
the camp kids because scott drew like 20
camp kids and i was like okay these are
all just going to be these generic camp
kids but um i got to write design doc
for like how what are all their
personalities and i really wasn't too
like
who like has a beef with who who has a
crush on who like what is the all the
interconnected social situations that
would prop up the camp
and i was like i'm so late on this
document i'm just going to go home i'm
going to write at home not going to go
to work for a while and it was right
about since a long time ago so this is
like early 2000's um
social media barely existed and the the
new hotness you know what the new
hotness was it was friendster oh boy
or facebook before myspace there was
friendster yeah
uh and everyone was into it because
they're like oh my gosh i can write a
little thing on my friend's wall i can
make up his jokes on my friend's wall
and everyone was into this like almost
the creative expression of it more like
it just like it wasn't a bunch of weird
things it was so pure tim what happened
it was just like let's let's like make
funny messages to each other and back
and forth it was oh let me tell you it
was so nice and um
and i was kind of obsessed with it and
it was distracting me from my work and i
was like oh god i've got to stop
hanging out on this this this platform
where we're all talking about to each
other and having all these relationships
and i got to go work on this document
about all these relationships and those
social situations and so i um
and then i realized that this is this is
the format that i need to work in i
couldn't figure out how to write a
design document that captured all this
network of relationships
um how could you ever write a design
talk as good as friends
so i did i made 20 fake friendster
profiles for them and they're still
online now if you if you find them i can
give you the url but they're still on
there and they're really rough they're
like um you know i made a fake profile
picture and i made you used to fill out
i'm like what's your favorite album
what's your favorite how old are you
where where did you grow up and i made
up things that are not even the i
wouldn't call these canon you know
because it's like i named places in
america where you really don't really
name places in america and something
else but anyway i named my uh favorite
album and then like what's you know they
had a little out friendster you had a
little like a collage you would make
like you could make put up six pictures
or something there's some limited number
of pictures you could put up and so it's
like if i wanted to represent each
character what six pictures would they
use to represent themselves so this is
kind of like they all made their own
little mood board and then the fun thing
was they would post on each other's
walls so i could have bobby the bully
like say mean things to vernon and
vernon and the kids started talking to
each other on these fake friendster
profiles and so it gave me all this
practice
off script like way away from the game
script just practice of like how might
these characters talk to each other you
know and they came like vernon maybe he
has a big christian crush on lily you
know and he's he's again fighting with
uh other people about it and um all
these relationships came out all these
weird little eccentricities like oh
maybe chops is really into hockey this
thing is really the hockey and um i
don't think i would have come up with
those specific details if i hadn't
really explored each character and tried
to think about what if they had to fill
out a form so now i kind of um i don't
make fake friendship profiles for every
character now but i do have like a
character sheet where i i try to fill in
a lot of basic detail about them like i
did on that form
and think about like do they grow up
rich or poor like they're always things
that you often don't think about your
characters like did they grow up rich or
poor was their family religious like if
you imagine them living somewhere on
earth even if a science fiction story
like
set another planet like where did they
grow up you know what was it like and um
did they have a you know both their
parents were they alive things about
their personality their identity
sexuality all these things like
you're just filling in all these
specifics for each character even if it
never comes up yeah in the game but
every once in a while the character will
drop a little like while you're kind of
improving the dialogue or whatever
character will be dropped like well you
know i love hockey or something and
hopefully it blends in with what what
they're saying or they tend to use
hockey terms you know stuff like that
talk about remember the time we went to
the hockey game where they just so you
grab really specific things when you're
writing your dialogue instead of just
generic like
you know coming up with it on the spot
something that is informed i um my
favorite of those questions on character
sheets is
what does this character want followed
by what does this character tell
everyone they want
yeah because i think that can be a super
interesting one in terms of like what do
they
think they want or what do they actually
want versus what do they project to
everybody that they want i feel like
it's so good at like showing
insecurities and motives in a really
interesting way do you have a favorite
character sheet question
well yeah i think that one also in
creative writing class they often say
what does character want and what does
the character need just like
different ways of describing a very
similar thing
um i really like picking favorite uh
albums just because we never talk about
i would never mention a real like
performer probably in the game but i
like thinking that chloe bargin and
psychonauts was really into hardcore rap
i remember that i came up it didn't ever
come up in the game but just like
knowing that
helped me that's awesome
yeah i mean it's how many how many uh
character sheets did you end up with the
second os two i feel like it's it's got
to be a lot all 20 camp kids i think
there's 20
but uh that sounds right
it's a lot of kids i don't know i like i
said i was just so impressed by like the
sense of camaraderie and really fell in
love with everybody was it was wonderful
oh and just the other example is on full
throttle um
the character maureen which um it's
often like you often get these
characters to the side characters they
don't get to do much except for like
help the main character achieve all
their goals and it often comes up with
these kind of you know flat characters
um so i was always trying to figure out
what maureen like the story from her
point of view like never tell a story
just from the main character's point of
view but like trying to think she's such
an important character like what is the
story happening from her point of view
well she meets this person and she likes
them but then she thinks that that
person killed her dad what would she do
she would go off and she would plot her
revenge and so i remember making a chart
for like here all the acts were this is
what ben throttle is doing
and here's what maury is doing because
she's off screen for a lot of it she's
like well she's getting her gang back
together and here's where she's plotting
her revenge
so next time you see her she's all ready
to go because she's had all this other
stuff she's gone through and i think it
helped her feel a little a little more
fleshed out you're right things can feel
very one note if they just exist to
serve the protagonist
worth trying to avoid it is time for an
ad break and this time i very
specifically wanted to talk to you about
a project that i've been trying to fund
that i'm very very excited about that we
have not yet managed to fund on patreon
the goal is currently 72 percent
complete this is a recurring d d show
which would feature cameos and
crossovers from multiple people across
my various podcasts it does have a core
crew of some people that i won't
announce just yet but two of them are
jacob and rahul and we are just about to
film what will effectively be the pilot
episode that is going to go exclusively
on patreon to begin with and then i will
probably release it publicly at some
point but i just wanted to encourage
people if you ever wanted a dnd show for
me that would you know i'm gonna ask
troy to have a part at some point i'll
probably ask austin and mike as well
i'll ask charlotte and fiona to jump in
you can support on patreon once we hit
that goal then i think that i can fund
us doing it probably once a month or so
so i'm basically just here to tell you
if this is a thing you hadn't heard of
you didn't know existed this is me
telling you about it you can support the
creation of the show on patreon.com
charolanazo and again i'll have a pilot
for you a very soon featuring two of my
recurring guests rahul and jacob and two
other wonderful guests that i'm also
very very very excited about so that
should be pretty awesome but i'm trying
to avoid spoilers here so patreon if you
want early access and if you want to
help us hit this goal so we can make
this show a reality i'm very very
excited about it now back to the podcast
so to ask you a broader question tim
what do you think makes a well-written
video game
oh man editing
it's fast
fair i mean
it's back up like
i always try and think of like how much
does this game need like some games
don't need a ton of writing and um
people definitely get really antsy um if
if the writing goes on too long i know
you thought seconds too had too many
cutscenes i saw that
but it's still that's edited down but
it's true
from where it started so you have to um
like you could never do enough of it and
i never i don't it was hard for me to
learn when i was in my 20s i was writing
and we were writing on mcallen
and um
we were told like you guys we can't go
on six floppies we have to go on five
we have too much text in this game which
is so hard to imagine given the assets
that we have in games now
digital video and everything that there
was too much tech like ascii text in the
game to fit on floppy's amazing so we
went in like we you know ron's like we
have to go and like cut 25 percent of
the dialogue and we're like what
i would look for 25
i think at least uh and i i went and i
would look at the scene i wrote and i
was like no that's i nailed it that's
perfect
it's perfect like every line that sets
up this joke this is more of a tone
thing and
and i went next door to hal barwood who
is our our local uh film uh
you know director who was in the office
with us making indian jones games fate
of atlantis at the time and he had a lot
of experience writing to film school
with george and he was he would talk
about the spider web and he was like
well you know it is hard but just
imagine your writing is like a spider
web
and some of the little strands of the
web are a little loose and if you cut
those it doesn't make the spiderweb
weaker it makes it more firm because the
other strands of the spiderweb are now
carrying more weight and it gets more
rigid and firm and tighter
and i was like whoa like as a metaphor
they say oh my god i totally opened my
eyes to like yeah
slash slash
go through scenes like this line of
dialogue does this does this line of
dialogue advance the story does it give
you any more information does it just is
it holding weight and if it's not it's
just there because
i felt it right i liked it
cut it out cut it out and like try and
get things down to like a few lines
because we i remember play testing in
the 90s like um
watching people play test monkey island
i'll just text and their hand would be
on the mouse this is my hand on their
mouse
and after three lines of dialogue always
their hands would start doing this like
tap tap what happened they really wanted
to play again like just three lines of
dialogue and they're already like i'm
ready to click again just stop talking
three is the barrier wow
i mean but that is a reality i'm glad
you brought it up because something that
i've spoken about on this podcast is
a lot of dialogue does get cut a lot of
cutscenes do end up getting
cut um in
various facets of game development how
does that process work narratively for
anybody who's not even familiar with the
concept of that happening like say
something gets cut
at late stages of development like what
is your job as writer slash director
to make that work um when you're like
there's too much video game in this
video game we got to get rid of some
stuff how do you make that
function when that decision has been
made
that's all i just think because if you
especially a narrative heavy game like
you might just oh we lost this level
this whole level i just had to go it's
not coming together it's we don't have
time let's cut it and then you're like
do we replace it with a cut scene like
sometimes it means extra work and more
dialogue because you like okay that
level is now a cutscene and we have to
like patch up this how do you know that
that person is the character's mother uh
i'll just write it
like you you know the writers are often
people who stitch together what gets cut
and you can't afford to have a cutscene
for anymore or you can't afford to have
a level
um hopefully you do i mean the all the
stuff i was talking about the positive
side of it is when writers do it
themselves so like this cutscene is like
five minutes long and i'm gonna get it
down to 30 seconds and i'm going to do
it and i'm going to make the spider web
tighter and it's going to be great um
that's that's good but often there's so
much thrash in game designs like um
you know we had this uh like like just
did you know we had this whole level
like imagine with sasha's cube where he
teaches you how to shoot and that was
the beginning of that and then designers
later were like we need combat earlier
than that so we're gonna add punching
we're going to make that combat earlier
i'm like this whole thing was set up for
like there was no
like this is the introduction of
conflict united all this like themes are
like this conflict this the game's
getting more intense here but then
design had you know we for design
reasons change things around it's like
narratively added just kind of like okay
i gotta reimagine how this this this
emotional thing so we're often like
scrambling to because you have to really
err on the side of you know what's right
for the design and then and then kind of
often you know scramble to even to um
to make it just makes sense first of all
makes sense
it's the whole thing
top to bottom
it is softened like
uh that's why i can't remember the exact
quote someone was talking once about how
you know fans sometimes they don't
understand games like why do we make
this choice why do we chose to do this
why do we choose that and they don't
realize that we are just
like caught in a [ __ ] tornado
in this hurricane trying to grab planks
of wood and like hook them together like
if we land safely at all it's a mirror
it's a very big hurricane
yeah it's a lot like it if you like
think it's five percent bad in this game
like oh my god i can't believe we fixed
95 of this game yeah
yeah it's a lot uh how cause my
criticism of psychonauts having too many
cutscenes was that the gameplay is so
good and i wish that more of the
dialogue was delivered while i could
still levitate you know how do you
decide what
dialogue is and again i'm sure this is
different for every studio what deli
dialogue is delivered
during gameplay and what is a cutscene
what's the distinction there
oh um i don't know i mean i usually i
think of cutscenes is like
um often we have to write them you know
way in advance the game development and
it would be like um big cinematic
cutscenes that are intros and outros of
of levels
and so that usually holds a lot of the
setup uh setting up the why you know
like you know why
why are you going into this level you
know and it serves this purpose of just
making the gameplay more heightened
because you know why you're doing it
like when ripley goes back into spoilers
for aliens too but um
what that current film
ripley ripley's safe and she yells
spaceship and go away but she's like
newt's still in there and she chooses to
go back in and it makes all the shooting
more exciting because you know why she's
doing it it's more dramatic if it's
delivered in a cutscene for sure yeah
that would be like a cutscene and then
often the gameplay stuff comes up with
like okay as we're testing level this
doesn't make sense
and it's often this is this just being
totally
realistic and practical the cutscene
stuff is often what you planned and the
interactive stuff is like what you're
doing to like um fix
because like no one knows why what that
they have to get three of these things
okay i'll have a line but i actually got
all three of these
you know it's it is often um
just kind of uh player hints and stuff
like that it is uh
again i appreciate the perspective
you're sharing here on how much of
writing is also problem solving for
other facets of
game development because that is
definitely definitely a thing
um if you
were able to
write on any game that's come out in
your entire career that you did not work
on what would it be and why
gosh
i just i think about this it's funny
because one of the games that i've
always been really jealous of him which
i've made is a little big planet and
doesn't have barely any writing at all
just it's such a creative game and it's
so much about the player's creativity i
think that was really uh
have you played a bunch of dreams
yeah i played through the superfly
campaign i tried to i was really
intimidated by like i can make anything
i want you know it's like wait this is
my job i do that too i i just won't do
it and then i'll but the stuff people
make in that game it's
so [ __ ] cool like i feel like dreams
is incredible like yeah it's really
awesome photo realistic [ __ ] like ugh
it's so rad
i don't have that talent
i can't do it
actually
not in dreams at least like the the uh
one of the first demos i saw was
somebody like crafting something out of
a move controller and i was like sure i
can do that and then tried it and i was
like turns out i can't um turns out they
could and i in fact cannot and that is
okay
um yeah but yeah
same by the same plan i'm gonna make a
level dreams i'm gonna make i'm gonna
i'm gonna start mocking up gameplay
ideas and dreams because so easy to use
and then i'm gonna make a level same as
a little big planet i always like had a
plan for making the whole big level but
i never did i think that's too close to
my job and i'm just i've got too much
just do that at work
are the other little games i really like
like um animal crossing like when i play
a sim like something simulating a town
it's like i'd love to like attend a
little town like that and just think
like like with the friendster pages like
thinking about the relationships of all
the characters and you know what you
often see in like a like like an old
dave lynch film like like blue velvet
like the town that he makes and the
relationships between the people is
always so interesting
well animal trusting is an interesting
one because you kind of invent the
relationships in a lot of ways like i
had had uh
townspeople that i hated but i had just
decided to they hadn't done anything
wrong i guess sometimes they can be
grouchy but it's an interesting one
because it's like the playa generally
simulating
how they actually feel about those
characters and how they they fill in the
blanks yeah and my daughter and i are
sharing an island and i would like try
and like dig holes around the characters
like isolate the character
no i like that one don't be you better
and she would know if i had like
you know not stopped one of them from
moving away you know they're like i'm
thinking about moving away like well you
should follow your dreams
you just bully them into leaving that's
certainly a dynamic
was very cute though
that kind of writing that kind of
writing just it was appealing i don't
know if i would ever actually do that
but it's very different um what do you
think some of the strengths of uh video
games as a medium in terms of
storytelling versus other mediums
that's that kind of implies that i am
intentional about what i do and i chose
this profession because i saw all the
power in it but i really just like
playing games and creative writing and
just
kind of lucked out but i mean games can
kind of haunt your brain in a way that
like um i mean movies and books do too i
think um they can do a lot of similar
things and that they
um
like great books and movies put you like
they give you i feel like it sounds dumb
when you say that like emotional
practice like i think like when you're
growing up or whatever you you can be
taken through an emotional situation
like you read a really dramatic book and
all that stuff happens you you kind of
go along with the characters i feel like
in the same way that like lifting
weights builds muscle i think you're
like
emotionally doing this kind of like
practice work so that when you have
things happen in your life there's like
a little bit of a little bit of
familiarity you have with like sadness
or grief or something because you've
been through these stories of characters
and i think games can do that too
it's very interesting way of putting
that do you feel like you recommend that
uh i'm just
i assume i already know your answer to
this but
um
a common tip for writers is to have them
suggest that they just read a lot is
that something that you would agree with
i mean it works for me i mean i uh i get
you it takes um
it takes more and more work the older
you get because i think there's a
certain point like late twenties
thirties where a lot of people became an
industry you're like i don't even have
time to play games anymore and they'll
say that like i'm so busy i don't i'm
not like well you're not gonna
come up with any more ideas because i
feel like
um
you it gets more something you have to
assign to yourself i got better yeah and
you're a game plan professional so you
are already like approaching it it's
already been a job for you for me four
hours of power wash simulator last night
let me tell you compelling story content
you do get texts that's kind of cute i
had to clean up the mayor's house last
night power wash simulator but the mayor
is really snooty so he wouldn't open the
gate so he had to clean the egg off of
his house through the gates
counts of storytelling somebody wrote
that
it sets that up power washer's face
ruined i would if i could if i found him
his cat's missing apparently you get
texts it's
it's a very i'm i couldn't i wouldn't
recommend power simulator to anybody
okay
it's literally what it sounds like tim
it's a game where you power wash stuff
that's incredibly satisfying i watch
power watch videos satisfying
but i think only to certain people but i
i do really appreciate that it has these
like little tiny chunks of story you get
texts from people asking you to do jobs
but some of them are really obnoxious
and rude and like it's it like they they
have writing in there in very specific
ways that i feel like it is very
engrossing and very cute like you know
the personality of the person you're
power washing for i've been to it
oh man now i have to try that but i do
think you have to read a lot and that's
that's also the thing they had to force
yourself to do because a lot of people
do like when i've taken public
transportation to work i've been really
caught up on my reading i like to read a
ton and then when something changes i'm
driving to work or i'm not you know are
in quarantine to home for a while i'll
just forget to read and it has an effect
on you because i really think
if you have a creative job you have to
be taking in stuff all the time and i
think because i think and i don't know
why this is maybe i think it's like a
caveman survival thing but like creative
people i think everyone is creative but
like
you can't help when you're taking in a
lot of something um to your brain starts
to go like can i make one of these i
don't know if i could make one of these
i start to like put them together and
like i was watching you know i got you
know i watched some a lot of board game
videos i'm watching i like board games
and i was like what if i could make a
board game video and then like why would
i do that
that's the last thing anyone in the
world needs is like a board game video i
don't want to see it for me yeah i kind
of want to see it
you can't help but like whatever you're
taking in you're like i should i wonder
if i can make one of these things um so
you got to play games because like you
play games and it's not like you
immediately
want to rip off what you see it's like
oh i'm going to make exactly this game
it's just that the game made you feel
something and you're like oh that was
great the way they made me feel that i
wonder if i could ever make someone feel
that way i wonder how i would achieve
that and you start to
be inspired to have these little atomic
elements that you picked up from games
you know like you know something like
uh olivia frenda spoiler for
gryffindango betrays you and just it's
like a little thing of that where you
watch the story and like someone you
trust betrays you and you're like oh i
wanna my next thing i wanna put someone
who really betrays you and it's like
that's just a common example of like
stuff but
that's what i mean like an atomic
element you don't just rip off the exact
way they do it yeah just oh i wonder if
i could achieve that or have um that
kind of moment
you have to have sources of inspiration
to be able to create things i think
that's a fair thing to say and i feel
like i find a lot of value in watching
uh movies including bad ones because
then i think about why i didn't like
them
and what i think the problem is and then
i reflect on things i've written and
been like oh that floor is there like um
i had a villain that was
just way too one note
and i watched a movie and i was like ah
kind of cruising with the villains way
too one note and then i was like [ __ ]
wait a minute
i've done that
that is terrifying when you're watching
a thing and you're like wow this is
terrible but i think i would have
written that line yeah i think that line
is funny like maybe they're not reading
it right or maybe i just think like i
could have fallen for i because it means
like sometimes it's terrifying yeah but
i think watching or consuming things
that you are critical of can also be
very helpful
for how you shape editing more than
anything as we say editing you love to
see it
um this is a question that i like asking
everybody uh and i i think i don't i
haven't had the same answer many times
at all what do you think is the future
of video game storytelling
how's it going tim where are the future
video games like 30 years where's it
headed and where's it going
oh gosh i mean i i'm always bad at
future telling i am always wrong about
the future that's okay you don't have to
be right
no one's gonna hold it against you
yeah i mean i think a lot about quality
like i i i don't want to be negative but
i think video game writing is largely
very bad like i think there's a lot of
bad writing and i don't mean people i
mean people are working what they have
and it's very hard to write for video
games because there's so many other
constraints and some of the most of them
many of them are higher priority usually
like gameplay performance and stuff like
that
uh at least in terms of the the
market and the final player and stuff um
so you're doing the best you can but i
think there's a kind of
kind of cliches i think you're one of
the things that i really
really bothered with me like just like
someone write a line like yeah that
works but it works because you've heard
it a million times and you know how it
fits in it's like oh there's a point in
my story where someone says lock and
load okay this is right this is the lock
and load scenario and
uh i would love it if games uh
pushed more towards improving quality by
avoiding cliches and stuff like that is
just the the quality level goes up you
know in games so i'm hoping that the
future game is better better writing
well that sort of seems inevitable
because i think that you're right like
i assume that double fine is a story
first studio like story's the first
thing that you work on in pre-production
uh we usually have every game was
different you know i'm brigade didn't
have any story but like uh
oh most of the games i work on it's like
it's like a more of a setup of like oh
the world actually it's more like a
world
the idea is like oh what's a good world
i'd like to explore and then what's the
main character and what do they want and
what the antagonists want and you know
and it goes from there so that counts
it's story first in that the person who
founded it and who can fire everybody is
the writer right so
and that's why i always feel bad
i recommend it for anybody i mean that's
that's the trouble is that i'm always
like my advice like it's 30 years old
and it's like be in charge here's my
advice to all writers be in charge it
really makes it easier because it's not
like you would um sacrifice things in
the game for the story but you don't
story is not immediately dismissed like
it often is in other discussions so like
you know if if the writer is the you
know in some games sometimes the writer
is just the programmer who has the most
free time or something like that
especially
not in a professional game situation
but um
this is this is the point in the podcast
where the daughter comes and tries to
lure the cat out of the room it's
working
hello kat
hi thanks for saying hi
okay here we go oh
hello there
very important side
[Laughter]
i love that that's like a job that she
has that's great i got somebody get this
dog you know it's mad when the cat's
been like um right here sleeping in
front of the under the camera the whole
time oh no way
troublesome kidnapping that's gonna
happen um well my my question was
phrased that way uh like outside of the
advice would be in charge santa monica
was also a writing first studio
um but there are a lot of studios out
there that aren't uh and i think one is
did they
did i say was no is it is not past tense
um i know like rockstar is but i think
there are a lot of uh studios both aaa
and indie that start with gameplay and
then the story has to fit in afterwards
and i feel like you know when you talk
about a lot of video game writing being
bad i don't disagree but i also think
it's because it's not a priority um i
have other friends who've
written on aaa projects who've been like
yeah they just handed me a level and
then said make a story work i'm like i
ca
i can't even imagine how hard that would
be and why anybody expects it to turn
out well that said in terms of quality i
feel like players are only appreciating
stories more and more and more
so hopefully it becomes clear like oh we
really need to focus on this thing if we
want please to be emotionally invested
in our games and thus give us more money
which is the whole point of the industry
thus he slipped in you're a super rider
evil villain
but uh i the thing i like is just that
and there's something special that
happened because i was hired as a writer
programmer like i could pro and i was
going to college for computer science
and i like creative writing and lucas
had this job posting for programmers to
be right so when we're solving problems
like everything you do is like solving
problems you're like i need the
character to understand that this is the
puzzle and i only get three lines to do
it in and also we need to progress their
relationship with this other character
something like that you're like how do i
solve that puzzle
and it's like i can solve it with
dialogue writing more i can write more
splines or i could
maybe you can solve it with um
level design or you can solve it with
programming and like i'll just do some
logic here i'll make where i'll do a
visual thing like we'll create some art
that tells it so like games have so many
levers they can pull
um and it's just great when they're all
considered you know equally in a way
like what is the right solution because
you know we could we could write a bunch
of dialogue here but the player will
appreciate not having a cutscene
so we can solve it with some gameplay
but the programmers are all busy like
you have to like just do this
negotiation with everything and
everything should be not you know
somewhat equal
priority so you can just find the right
solution and sometimes it is just who
has time
i mean oh the animators are busy let's
just i'll write a piece of text we'll
have a piece of something like depends
where you're on production oh it's the
last it's the end of production you've
got to just put up a dialogue yeah do
you think uh writer programmer job
listings go out much anymore
i don't know i don't know people you
know i think i imagine at indie studios
that's still a thing but i can't imagine
that exists much anywhere else what a
wild
hybrid to have gotten how many people
worked on secret and monk yeah how big
was that team well it was wrong and it
was me and dave and then it was um
that was the programming team and a
couple more people maybe on the engine
like eric and then downstairs three
artists who also animated
wow
it was pretty small and then uh three
musicians two one musician that one the
first one so it's pretty small it only
took nine months
also if i remember it changed so much
again with 2d games without voice we're
so easy to make
let's go back to those
the voice adds a lot but now we have to
like we're changing text also
localization is tied in there because
like we didn't localize we didn't have
voice so like we were changing lines of
monkey on the day before we shipped like
wow
you know like let's solve this puzzle
with the change in the text no way damn
that's crazy how many people do you have
it uh double fine
like 70.
except
they were all in psychonauts at the end
so they gave you complicated they're
complicated now it's so complicated yeah
but again i appreciate you talking about
it because it's a thing that i feel like
it helps people understand like it's
it's an important thing for us to be
often still like that now right yeah
what uh what was the the biggest
challenge you had of all the games that
you've worked on so many games tim so
old you know i'm sorry
what do you feel like it's the biggest
challenge you've had in your entire
career in terms of you know i mean a
game that stood out was hard to make
like there's like practical challenges
like we run out of money several times
that's tough it's psychonauts resign so
there's a lot of biz dev challenges that
probably are less interesting but
they're just part of it um oh i forgot
about that that was like the xbox thing
right with the original psychonauts yeah
that's nuts that's why microsoft bought
us just to make up for dropping us
[Laughter]
how can we we can finish this
psychonauts game and that way we'll make
up for knobs
it's a long it's a long run but they
came back in the end
blood off is complete
yeah and brutal legend too got um
switch publishers in the middle of it
because the first publisher yeah
went south so um there's a lot of that
challenges but um
there's there's interpersonal challenges
like conflicts in the team that's a big
big struggle
um
but i'm trying to think of big
challenges because it's often so easy
for us to just piece a cake
i mean i do feel like funding is a big
one that also people don't realize um
you know metal health singer have you
seen that
it's not out yet the demo very very cool
um and there that studio's previous game
got cancelled and i did an interview
with david goldberg who's the uh
creative director of the outsiders
studio and there were some comments
where people were like i'm not going to
watch this because i'm still mad at them
for cancelling their previous game i was
like you know they didn't cancel it yeah
what
it played
so they couldn't make the game and like
like how do you think people's salaries
get paid
he didn't cancel the game it's very very
weird to see that that disconnect of
like that is such a big reality of
having a face and games are
incomprehensibly expensive i understand
that i work at a triple a studio that's
working on a very large video game but i
have no comprehension of cost it's just
huge the answer is very large lots of
money and i don't know where it comes
from and i'm scared
it's just a lot you are i haven't talked
to you since you crossed to the other
side
in one of us now we have seen each other
since then but we have not spoken about
it no
you've just expressed uh empathy for
game development
yeah like so
as it do you find yourself now playing
games going like oh i know why they did
that oh they must have oh i guess the
programmer was sick
yeah i think i do understand disconnects
a little bit more but it's also funny
because it's like
it's definitely harder than i expected
it's harder than i i everyone always
says it's hard and everyone always told
me it would be hard but it's definitely
harder than i expected it's it's
difficult i love it though it's like
such a rewarding challenge working on a
video game in this capacity um yes i
don't know other like i said i don't
know how to be right unless you're in
charge it's just hard to imagine but
you know i still i still serve the game
and serve the team when i'm writing on
it like and if the designers and the
people are like okay we totally changed
this level because we need to give you
this weapon first
sometimes i do love scrambling to make
that work okay now i'm going to make
that i'm going to rewrite that cutscene
so character really likes that weapon
i'm just going to just making something
look like it was intended the entire
time is part of the fun challenge of it
often i mean here's a completely
ridiculous change to the character and
i'm going to make it like part of his
essential backstory
i feel like a party a job that i imagine
is probably pretty difficult that the
public doesn't know about
it's your job to make sure everybody
else is excited
like that's on you that is the tim
schaefer has to make sure everybody else
on the team is excited about what
they're making and is excited to make
the thing and i think that's a very
important part of working on a game for
several years is making sure that people
want to show up and do that thing and i
feel like that's got to be
a pretty significant challenge just
managing the excitement of 70 people
i mean my technique and i didn't really
plan this but it was just like how it
happened looking back on it is that i'm
really excited
like the only reason i started game is
because of like a couple ideas that come
together in my head like oh my god this
has to be a game i'm really excited
about it and the same for pitching into
a publisher or talk pitching game to
your team it's just that you're excited
just let yourself be excited about it
and talk about it and everyone will just
it's contagious people are like oh my
god that is exciting and like they sense
how excited you are and they get excited
about it too and so it just gets it
spreads that way and so i feel like
that's how it's always approached it and
the thing you have to remember is to
keep sharing that and share it all
through development would often be you
got important psychologists who are like
could you guys you know a lot of us
don't know what the story of psychonauts
2 is and in my head i'm like what are
you talking about i wrote that document
like two years ago
i put it on i put it on the network
right everyone read it right like in my
mind everyone knows about how much of
the story that i know because it's so
fresh in my mind at all times and
everyone else is like we don't
understand it so i like at
um a point certain point in the
development right i thought everybody in
the store i did a whole like okay you
guys here's the story of second last two
and i went over the whole thing and the
team was like oh
i don't know why we just assume everyone
understands the story but they don't and
there's new people on the team and the
story gets changed
it's just good to like re-pitch your
story to the team like two times at
least during development like halfway
through and then like did you do that as
like a video meeting rather than like a
doc because i feel like you can only
expect people to get so much from a word
doc or whatever
i did there was a word doc no one read
and if they didn't read it it's just
comprehension is hard with written
things i'm done so i um i pitched to
like a powerpoint meeting to everybody
we recorded it and put it up for people
to watch that video late i pushed it on
another live thing people like to like
because that's the part about sharing
your excitement like i'm excited this is
where this whole twist is coming in the
story and people are like oh i get to
animate that scene with a big twist in
it oh that's cool it's true so would you
agree that's an important part of the
whole thing is like you have to be
excited and engaged to make sure
everybody else on the team is excited to
carry a purchase people don't get paid
enough really this is a ridiculous
industry so
they could all be making money and uh
wall street or something i don't know i
don't know especially the program the
amount of money that like programmers
and engineers can make elsewhere bless
them for giving us their skills you know
we don't deserve any of them like you
could be making money for amazon my
friend
love that you're here attract someone
who wants to do something cool because
games are pretty special in that
there's not that many things you get to
work on that involve the collaboration
of so many
different disciplines yeah you know of
like
writers and programmers extremely
technical programmers gameplay
programmers
artists modelers 2d artists
animators musicians like singers like
actors um all just like across the gamut
of like every art people do
um gets pulled together into into games
and it's really fun to collaborate with
that many people and so that's a special
kind of programmer who's like i want to
be part of that crazy production you
know i don't want to
do some back-end stack thing but i know
she drew a couple buzzers out back in
stack is that anything i don't think so
yeah i don't think that exists
no not a thing we should have it and get
rich all right let's do it straight to
silicon valley let's go
um
i think that that's my favorite thing
about working
uh in
i guess the games industry in general
but um
like it blows my mind that
i get to talk to so many people who are
absolute experts in one particular thing
and that i just get to ask them
questions and it's such different things
um like the person who is head of ai i
could just go ask them whatever i want
like that it just feels wild to have
access to so many extremely
talented people of such varied vocations
like you're talking about who all just
come together and make something
incredibly cool and it's all really
really hard but it's yeah from
completely different skill sets which
i don't know another industry that
functions that way we're a pretty
special bunch
that's pretty cool
trying to re-convince the programmers
not to please
don't leave don't go work at amazon your
soul will die you really need to fire in
your belly and you'll be like what have
i done with my life never require a fast
amount of still have so much money
though so so much money though yeah you
never got to worry about healthcare
again um which is great for you um you
don't have enough money to start your
own game company so
full circle baby
you need this experience
um before i let you go
tim um i'm gonna ask you from my
perspective but give this to people who
have
yeah it's just anyone what's your advice
for new writers
people who want to write video games or
people who've just started writing video
what's your what's the the one thing
you've learned that you would pass on or
the one thing that you think is the most
valuable
thing you can say in a sentence
yeah i mean besides all the stuff that
people always say probably like read a
lot and bunch of games and write every
day like there's all the kind of uh free
writing is something i really believe in
i'm a little notebook right here that i
try to i didn't do it this morning
that's a good reminder like i write long
hand in this phrase someone told me like
you know the killer in seven are they
writing these like books and filled with
books notebooks that you you're like
that guy i take all of my work notes in
uh physical notebooks because it helps
me remember better
it's this thing we started in seventh
grade the english teachers okay okay you
got the the rule is your pen has to
constantly be moving for like two
minutes it started two minutes and you
can't stop even if you're writing pure
gibberish and so you try and do that
blah blah blah blah blah you're not
you're not really working on anything
because if you stop for a second to
think you've like lost that thing so if
you're just forcing yourself to write
the same word over and over again then
eventually you turn off that editor
inside your brain and your brain starts
flowing and that's because that's where
when i get stuck on something creatively
sometimes it unstucks unstucks me to um
have lunch with someone or like talk to
someone about the problem and even if
they don't say anything helpful i've
talked to i start unlocking the problem
by talking about it it's a weird verbal
totally
your brain so free writing does that for
me sometimes i'll like i've gone to the
office i remember it because i was
really asleep because i kind of want to
work today but i got to do the street
running the road and then i pooped out
an entire game like design like ohio
like a basic premise for a game that i
never made but i was like this is
amazing page after page i've never heard
of that before
i have not free writing no yeah i've
never heard of it before good to do it
like every day even if it's like five
minutes i try to do it for an hour like
i tried to write filth two pages or
something it's really hard i feel like
it's hard as i get older to stay focused
to like stay right because i just drift
off to do oh yeah sorry to do so it's
like a disciplined thing but it's a
creativity and a creative unblocking
thing that's really cool
free writing give it a try
um
and the other thing is that back that we
talked about editing because i think a
lot of people don't learn that edit
because they never were forced to do it
because games can hold as much as they
you want now and some of the big budget
games you're like yeah we have a eight
minute cutscene here that okay you know
like no one ever comes and says like
we're out of space for text you gotta
cut it for 25
and um
and second last two i'd write a scene
like that's done and i would edit it and
whatever it was done and then it would
come back in an animatic form and i was
like wait this cutscene is way too long
and they don't have to kind of fight
with the animators to cut it i feel like
it's too long you cut this out like oh
we already storyboarded it like no no no
it's going to be encoded so so um
forcing yourself to to
after you put something aside for a few
days go back to it reduce it to like 75
it's original size i think is always a
good exercise so editing how do you
right how do you uh
if you have any tips i don't know if you
could even make that oh hello good
morning oh somebody's walking around oh
big stories
um how do you choose like what are the
things that that
if you have any that automatically get
edited
um i mean i often spend a lot of time
just with uh
at the beginning of a scene just a lot
of like mumbles like just like huh what
huh like there's a lot of just warming
up a scene that i can just cut out like
there was like a i think kurt vonnegut
had a little article about like how to
write he's like just take the first page
of your short story and throw it away
because that's just you
that i've never even heard someone say
that before but of every short story or
story i've ever written i could always
get rid of the first few pages because
it's i realize it's just for me it's not
actually for the reader
and it's it's like what kurt vonnegut
said is like that's just you trying to
make the reader like you
thank you i'm going to tell you a story
would you please like me and just cut
all that out and it's a beginning of
cutscenes are often the same way you're
just trying to
set the tone but you know the player
just wants to get in and get out just
like give them the facts just the facts
and so um in that elsewhere in that
volume article he's like go look at
every single line your thing and like
does this advance either give you new
information
um set up a question there's like the
list of things like important
load-bearing things yes it advance the
story somewhat does it tell you new
information about character you didn't
know before and if i don't do any of
those things just cross it out and
you'll notice like if you cross it out
oh yeah everything works without that
line and then you just do that through
your whole thing that's a huge thing in
game reviews of all the game reviews
that i've edited um
getting rid of any sentence that doesn't
tell me if the game is good or bad is a
really easy go-to
it's just does this sentence exist to
tell me if the game is good or bad or
you like the game is actually a better
way to phrase that if you do does this
sentence tell me that nope i don't care
what it says get rid of it but if you
get what if you're getting paid by the
word though
[Music]
then then
just leave on on the end of the sentence
and that is good
and then
there you go
i don't think that happens anymore tim i
don't know if people out here getting
paid by the word these days
gets paid anymore
it's a journal
that's how my career started i started
as a volunteer completely as a volunteer
writer so i wasn't getting paid for like
three years before i i finally got paid
for my first uh game review which is in
a print magazine
not charming here i am like a printout
of one of your youtube videos they just
printed a youtube video out and i was
like pay me for it now but it was really
nice because
my parents had told my grandma what i
was trying to do for a living but she
didn't really grasp video games and
writing now i just say i write movies
grandma and she gets that
same thing what's the difference um but
the minute that we had a physical
magazine to sent her
um the one that i sent her i think was
my review of company of heroes 2.
then she got it she was like it says by
alana pierce and i was like yeah yes
i wrote it and then everything was fine
and now she's proud of me i think oh
sweet that was nice yeah he worked out i
uh
you know just a lot of my motivations
just trying to
make my family happy that's a lot of a
lot of life i just
do what we can my dad's coming to visit
in a couple of weeks he keeps asking me
if i can figure out a way to cast him in
god of war as an australian dragon
australian dragons are those different
well it's very australian accent my
dad's so australian that i sometimes
have to translate for him when he visits
he will just leave the subtitles on yes
hold on he's there he will just talk to
people
full australian accent and slang and not
recognize that people won't understand
that so we'll be like in an uber and i
have to go
he means this
gotta put this in a video now now i
totally want to see this it's pretty
great i was thinking about getting uh
dad to help me do an australian slang
video because he is very very aussie but
uh that's the australian dragon i think
it's a great idea
yeah i don't know that it works in god
of war devastatingly
dad i hope you're not watching this
psychonauts 3 you need an australian
dragon my dad he's got you
well we went with a new zealand actor
i'm never going to tell him
those magazines like i used to get
magazine and i was embarrassed like i
got interviewed and i would i didn't
want to be like showing off so like hide
them and then i found that my dad got a
hold of some of them and like had him
he's a doctor he like had him in the
waiting room of his office for other
people to read and it never would occur
to me that my dad would be proud of
these magazines like i was like oh i'm
gonna start bringing these home you know
that's really sweet
it's a shared experience i guess it is
sweet when when you said it was sweet
that my grandma did it i was like i
guess and then you say it and i go oh
it's so cute it is sweet
there we go
um all right tim i won't keep you any
longer what are you up to where can
people find you
nowhere i'm hiding i'm hiding working on
new stuff i can see you right now
uh are you aware that your camera is not
doing very well
uh a double fight you can play
psychonauts too some gameplay
thank you you know we're approaching the
one year anniversary of second hosting
can you believe why not for you what is
time
i don't know and i like it
i'm scared
uh that's awesome congratulations how
long has it been since the acquisition
two years three years it must be three
then
[Music]
there you go what is time go so covered
i know i absolutely ruined my concept of
time entirely
yeah it's messed up everything yep
because there's no landmarks for those
years no i was thinking like i didn't
get a haircut for like three years so
it's gotta be
there's time anymore um but otherwise
you are on twitter
yeah tim of legend everywhere yep
because i
not because i think i'm great because i
was promoting brutal legend when i
signed on for twitter
now you just stuck with it
and i'm stuck with it uh you look like a
big jerk
yeah i've never thought about it to be
fair at no point did i think wow what an
egotist maybe because i know you but
also you've got to promote yourself you
know no one's put yourself out there
that's how you get to
the perfect piece of advice that we got
from this podcast is run the studio and
be the writer in charge
call yourself tim of legend that's how
you do it
yeah you're an inspiration
yeah just uh if you're not in charge act
like you're in charge eventually you
will be i don't know that that works
that way i think that
[Laughter]
thank you for watching everybody thank
you so much for joining us tim thanks
for having me next time
[Music]
you